how did you first hear about virtual
production virtual production really
became big and known from the uh
Mandalorian TV show from Disney and
that's kind of like where I got a taste
of it and really heard about it um and I
was like 2019 around covid maybe 2020 um
but yeah that's that's when I first
really heard about it and really started
extensively researching it um and saw
the the power and the capabilities and
all the things what can be done with
that really can benefit and help people
and filmmakers and companies um with
film with filming for their whever
they're trying to shoot whatever project
how many movies or TV shows can you name
right now that you feel use Virtual
production there's lot many Laur I
mentioned one it's a space movie with
Tom
Cruz I don't remember off my head but
there there's uh Lion King the lion king
used it um there's been a lot of it's a
lot of commercials have used it for
stuff for like airplane stuff um car
process stuff commercial commercials for
like Samsung or whatever like cell phone
commercials in a car um they don't have
to actually go drive out in the street
so they use Virtual production or and
camera view effects which they parallel
so how did you decide to build your own
studio so this whole studio came about
um couple years ago let's see I was
location scouting for a project in
Lancaster in the desert and um I was
already researching Ro production and
looking into it and saw the benefits of
it um but when I was in Lancaster I was
driving out there I was in my Jeep and
uh I go on this hill Hilltop area and of
course my I'm like I'm don't know where
my Jeep gets
stuck so we get stuck in the sand the
second time this happened like a year
before it happened but anyways I get
stuck in the sand I'm out the middle of
nowhere the transmission blows out like
transmission's done cuz I'm trying to
get out of there yeah it took me like an
hour to get a tow truck out there and
then he barely could get out there to
where I was um so that was like for me a
big turning point to where I was like
you know what that is like a perfect
example of what virtual production can
do for people and help people and
companies on achieving a production
where they don't have to go to the
deserts and get stuck in the sand or
they can't access the location or just
the the harsh heat the climate so many
different things um and then the long
drive to get to the deserts like
Lancaster is an hour and a half from
here hour and 40 minutes so that was
kind of what really sparked my my final
green light to say I'm going to go ahead
and do this CU I just saw it firsthand
like that's just is such a benefit to
not have to deal with that and you have
bathrooms locally it's climate
controlled in the studio you don't have
to worry about that versus like getting
porta potties out to where you're
filming and craft services and base camp
it's all done in the studio easy so
after after you got your car home yeah
you you started researching um
Alternatives right I mean I already was
looking in the virtual production but
that was kind of like my
final my final say so of like
greenlining going ahead and doing this
and starting virtual Studio because of
that incident what happened um is just
like I mentioned some of the benefits
but that's just one of them I mean that
can change if you're getting a cast and
crew of 20 people out to the desert or
snow mountains and people are getting
stuck it's just going to Productions and
like cost your team more money versus
you go to a virtual Studio everything's
there like I said before like bathrooms
your you know craft Services your base
camp you know where we're getting stuck
everything's easily right there within a
few feet of you versus having to do all
the traveling and gas for people so it's
extra expenses um but yeah that's what
was my big Turning Point how how hot was
it when you were there good question
that was I should have touched based on
that um that was actually so that was in
201 20 22 I believe or early 2022 um it
was right during the middle of a heat
wave or this the beginning of a heat
wave what just started I didn't know
when I went out there that we were in a
heat wave because it was like day one or
two of the Heat Wave and I just thought
like I got out there and like wow it's
really hot out here it was like early
September and I was like it is freaking
scorching hot out here like I didn't
think I took my shirt off cuz I was like
waiting for the tow truck and it was
like 115 and I had like a bottle of
water and like a snack bar and that was
it and um yeah was beginning of a heat
wave a heat Dome I guess we had in La I
think it was early 2022 like I said
September around that time and um that's
another thing so just the heat yeah it
was it was bad so that was what also
influenced me like wow look at that
people don't have to deal with that I
mean how you how you go film out in a
desert in
115° like you can't you have to wait I
mean people are going to pass out that's
liability for you um you have medical
staff on standby so yeah versus a
virtual Studio on the deal with that how
does virtual production factor into your
plans to continue film making yeah I
mean I have my own personal projects
that myself as a company's producing as
well they put out and um you know for
the public to see and for distribution
uh later down the road I've been really
focusing on with my team managing the
studio for the most part this past year
since it's been open um but as far as
film making currently like with stuff I
have uh we did like two years ago uh two
oneoff like TV Pilots I guess you could
say one was called Su city which now on
2btv and like Vimeo on demand and then
we also did a oneoff of a uh for X-Men
fans called there ay Cyclops Chronicles
the story of Scott Summers of the
Cyclops character from X-Men for X-Men
fans not for distribution just for fun
for entertainment purposes for people to
see um anyways we're taking both of
those oneof Pilots now when we're taking
that into the virtual Studio here and
we're continuing it in Virtual
production entirely in Virtual
production 100% And the purpose of that
is to demonstrate and show people the
capabilities and the power of virtual
production what can really be done and
how it you know how it looks on camera
and how it can benefit people and help
people to achieve something in a short
amount of time um and just in general
what virtual production you know what
can be done with it would just a whole
series in general of whatever project
they're trying to make so that's what
I'm working on now and we're in
post-production on those two series I me
how did you teach yourself virtual
production and how much of a learning
curve is there wellow it was um you know
that was uh it was a long process and I
started with learning on real engine
myself which is the the Gameware
software program for people who don't
know what that is um we call it a 3D
asset in ver production what's put on
the LED wall so we use LED wall be
projection for virtual production here
at the studio and um yeah I started with
just like going online going on YouTube
and then reading online and then I
started messing with it myself um on my
computer I downloaded on real engine
started learning that and then when I
was researching virtual production in
general and reading about it I got kind
of how it worked sort of but you know I
tell filmmakers and directors and
cinematographers will come in here it's
hard to grasp what it is just by
watching on YouTube and like reading
about it you you won't know until you go
out and experience it yourself like
anything experience rules everything in
life on whatever you're trying to do
that's number way number one way you
will learn so I didn't really until I
opened the studio and really learned I
didn't really learn all the technical
aspects involved in Virtual production
and how it really works until I opened
the studio and learned by experience and
it was a lot of trial and error a lot of
just Tech shooting tons of months of
that and just really learning um before
I made it publicly available for people
to come in and rent out so um so it was
a big learning curve and a lot of work
um but uh yeah there's a whole you know
know a couple different aspects of R
production and one is the camera
tracking solution since what we what we
use here to create what we call Parallax
on the wall which is the LED wall moving
in the background and Unison with the uh
on engine gaming
software and did you have to get a new
computer or you already had one that was
compatible I did I had to get a a a PC
with the graphic card with talked to a
couple buddies and people in the
business I knew what recommended I get a
certain PC and the the right graphic
card to power on engine so there's no
problems um so yeah I did have to get a
a good PC to have
that so in in addition to the PC the
software and then the LED wall any other
things that you need that you can share
sure no absolutely so so I'll kind of
touch based on BR production like the
different elements and what what's
needed and how it works um so you have
your LED walls your rear projection
right then you have your your computer
computer um with on engine on it what's
then everything's connected from the LD
wall you have a a processor controller
what powers LD wall um and then like I
said the computer and then if you have
if you're using UNR engine you have that
what gets displayed on LED wall um and
then for unun engine you have your
camera tracking solution what's
basically a camera tracker what gets
mounted on top of the camera and that
camera tracker gets paired in unison
with a um with a in-game camera There's
an actual camera in under engine called
a c camera it gets paired with that
through a um a plugin right so it gets
paired and Us in and when it's paired
through the the plugin it it's it
creates what we call parallx on the wall
which is the shifting of the LED panels
which is really it's creating this 3d
effect that you're actually there
instead of a static wall um when the
actor is moving left and right in front
of the screen or forward or backwards or
whatever um and the cameras moving with
them it's it's the wall is moving
perspective the wall is moving
perspective with the actual actor
because of that camera tracker so um
that is one of the big elements of
virtual production so you don't have
that static wall so so yeah and then you
have you know your lighting elements you
make sure you light it properly um frame
it shoot it on the right lens what you
want and um put it with the right
foreground practicals and that's how
really helps facil fa itate this Vision
that you're somewhere else in the
world